though is an intergalactic tyrant to
whom earth is just one planets among
millions Thanos had a strangely human
experience and Avengers infinity war
somehow the mad Titan instantly
recognized Tony Stark as he armored
Avenger iron man when the pair brought
on the planet Titan so how exactly did
fellows know who Tony was in the
commentary track on the Avengers
Infinity Ward digital release director
Joe Russo revealed that Thanos
recognized Tony as a person who failed a
scheme to seize power over Earth through
Loki in 2012 see Avengers Brousseau
explains he's aware of start from the
original Battle of New York as a person
who indid the plan
[Applause]
essentially the purple-faced titan knew
who tony was an infinity war for the
same reason tony predicted that an
enormous threat was coming to earth and
the avengers they are both as Santos
says in the film curse with knowledge as
Rousseau noted this results in a source
of existential connection between Thanos
and Tony while Tony spent years pouring
blood sweat and tears into upgrading his
armor to nanotech levels and keeping a
close eye on what lies ahead fellows did
the same in devising a plan to wipe out
half the universe's population in order
to clear a path for a better future when
the two have been on their own their
plans have gone mulleted li smoothly
it's only when the two faceoff
indirectly in the Avengers and directly
in infinity war at each derail the
others forward momentum
Russo went on to explain the journey
that Tony's been on as a genius
scientist is the evolution of his armor
this is the best it's ever gonna get for
Tony he goes to the cutting edge of what
his mind can deliver and it still is not
enough to beat Thanos in fact it barely
keeps him in the fights Infinity Ward
co-screenwriter Christopher Marcus also
pointed out the major similarity between
the mad Titan and the genius billionaire
playboy philanthropist both of them of
concrete visions regarding what a
perfect future would look like despite
holding wildly different ideas about how
to reach that end goal I see a suit of
armor around the world sounds like a
cult World time I've seen colder be the
starways in your
so yeah they have slightly different
plans in mind still Marcus elaborated on
their connection saying you realize this
interesting parallel between Thanos and
Tony
they're both aware of something from an
early point and constantly having to
deal with being smarter fallows is a
futurist as much as Tony Stark
although Infinity Ward didn't address
Sano's has linked to Tony beyond the
mention that they both bear the burden
of wisdom this actually isn't the first
time Bruce Willis discussed the Perce
connection speaking with the Telegraph
in the air ahead of the film's release
the director mention that all the heroes
in the movie are Thanos his enemy but
the mad Titan has the most Pacific
connection to Tony because they both
have plans for the world
he's a futurist and I think a brilliant
future so he understands where the world
is going getting down to brass tacks
Thanos and Tony have a heck of a lot
more in common than one might assume and
the mad Titan even apparently holds Tony
in high esteem telling him that he has
respect near the end of infinity war but
this doesn't necessarily mean that we
can view Thanos and Tony is
fundamentally the same after all one is
a galactic warlord who commits genocide
on a universal scale and the other is an
ex-military weapons manufacturer working
hard to protect people so despite their
similarities don't expect them to be
sitting down for shawarma anytime soon
[Music]